ich lehne mich aus dem fenster über
morgen erleben wir alle die spannendste
wahl des jahres in thüringen und wenn
sie zu hause jetzt sagen thüringen was
war das noch mal hier unser service die
heute show stellt vor
alles was man über thüringen wissen muss
[Musik]
bei den dreharbeiten war das übrigens
ein krakauer manchmal muss ich zugeben
ist diese sendung wirklich ein einziges
klischee festival da schämt man sich
natürlich ist thüringen vielmehr als
wurst ja thüringen ist zb auch wald und
wald und noch mehr wald und natürlich
bäume nicht zu vergessen jede menge ein
wunderschönes land mit gerade mal 2,1
millionen einwohnern braucht man dafür
wirklich eine regierung
reichen da nicht zwei drei first nur als
frage nur als frage dem thüringen
jedenfalls geht es eigentlich ganz gut
stabiles wirtschaftswachstum
arbeitslosenquote unter dem ost
durchschnitt obwohl das land von einem
linken regiert wird bodo ramelow wie
seine fans ihn nennen
der herr der thüringer ramelow aktuell
der beliebteste politiker des landes
ob er ministerpräsident bleiben darf
weiß allerdings keiner da ist alles noch
völlig offen schauen sie 38 prozent der
bevölkerung haben sich noch nicht
entschieden ich finde das aufregend ich
finde das spannend ich finde es auch
großartig dass eine wahl auf einmal zu
einer wahl wird klar das kennt man nicht
in der ddr
spaß ist basso wie kriegt man eine
mehrheit in thüringen wahrscheinlich gar
nicht das ist die schlechte nachricht
nach aktuellen umfragen reicht es nur
noch für eine kombination aus
linkspartei mit cdu
es klingt irgendwie pervers die
bratwurst mit nutella oder sowas
immerhin hat der cdu-spitzenkandidat
mohring frische ideen wie man
abgewanderte thüringer wieder
zurückkommen könnte mit gilt ja wollen
unser wahlprogramm formulieren dass es
eine 5000 euro prämie gibt wenn man
zurückkommt in den thüringen
arbeitsplatz finden und sich diese
prämie noch mehr erhöht werden auch
kinder in der familie dabei sein wird
auch junge familien auch den weg wieder
nach thüringen zurück gehen 5000 euro
kriege ich die auch wenn ich nur meine
kinder der arbeiten schicken
ja weil sonst müsste ich ja nach
thüringen ist ja quatsch so und dann
gibt es natürlich noch die bange frage
vor diesem kommenden sonntag wie gut
schneidet bernd höcker von dem der
spiegel neuerdings schreibt sein stern
in der afg würde siegen kann sich das
vorstellen sinken ja der bern schreibt
der spiegel werden der parteien nur noch
ein und ich zitiere maskottchen motto
seines wahlkampfs ist wende 2.0 und da
wird wieder mal die gewählte regierung
merkel mit der ddr-diktatur
gleichgesetzt was zeigt wie viel respekt
vor unserer parlamentarischen demokratie
hat nun mal fürs protokoll ja der typ
hier hat im jahr des mauerfalls als 17
jähriger im westen gelebt es fühlt sich
schon wieder so an wie in der ddr
liebe freunde
und dafür haben wir nicht die friedliche
revolution gemacht liebe freunde das
wollen wir nie wieder erleben hier
wir vergessen schien gefallen ist die
moore am ende wegen einem bademeister
aus kalifornien und dem 17 jährigen
bernd aus lünen nrw gut ab ansonsten
schwadronierte gern vom zitat volkstod
durch bevölkerungsaustausch also der
verschwörungstheorie auf die sich alle
rechten mörder von christchurch bis
halle berufen
ach ja und in der schule will er mehr
schreibschrift untersuchungen haben
nachgewiesen dass gerade die verbundene
schreibschrift die sorgfalts liebe des
kindes fördern
[Applaus]
wo er recht hat sieht so einfach schöner
ausfindig und obwohl oder weil höcke im
zusammenhang mit dem dritten reich von
einer dämlichen bewältigung politik
spricht finden ihn aktuell 71 prozent
der thüringer fdp anhänger nicht zurecht
sondern zitat genau richtig so viel zum
thema bürgerliche partei hier original
spot wir sind in sorge
und mit zerfall der inneren sicherheit
wir sind vor allen dingen sorge
erstaunt umso frau
wir sind in sorge
kultur wie
in sorge ja ich weiß nur mal kurz für
sie zusammen erst entsorge glaube ich
aber vom look und vom pathos her fand
ich super oder diese dramatik das will
ich auch
ich bin in sorge weil auf thüringer
marktplätzen schon weder blonde frauen
und kinder von schul jährigen
trickbetrügern aus dem westen
abgeschrieben werden ich bin in sorge
weil deutsche männer ohne hilfe treppen
hoch laufen müssen während ausländer im
goldenen selten durch die gegend
getragen werden ich bin in sorge weil
die musik schmerz muss zum arzt und der
arzt bestimmt ausländer
danke danke und ich bin in sorge weil
wir kein anderes wort über einzeln aus
ich will den sorgen wird am 27
oktober
[Musik]
erst im sommer
[Applaus]
das hatte sein ganzes gift verbreiten
darf beweist übrigens dass bei uns
meinungsfreiheit herrscht auch wenn die
afg gerne das gegenteil behauptet aber
zurück zur bodo ramelow
was war das sie erinnern sich für eine
panik 2014 als der erste linke
ministerpräsident wurde oder eine panik
dabei hat er seitdem in thüringen keine
einzige kolchose gegründet nichts
verstaatlicht wieso ist der mann gegen
den trend als linker im osten so
erfolgreich um das herauszufinden habe
ich sogar einen privat detektiv
engagiert und zwar den billigsten
[Musik]
der fall bodo bescheuerter vorname wer
baggert da so spät noch am baggerloch
das ist der bodo mit dem bagger und der
bart noch mal kurz abgelenkt fünf jahre
habe ich den ramelow der in thüringen
beschattet jetzt ist mir was klar
geworden da fliegt ihnen der draht aus
der mütze bodo ramelow ist überhaupt
nicht in der linkspartei
[Musik]
doch ich meinen ich hätte das schon mal
irgendwo gelesen ja wo denn auf seinen
wahlplakaten jedenfalls nicht freund
bodo versucht alle verbindungen zu
dieser kommunisten bande zu verschleiern
nirgendwo ein logo der linken dafür sehr
konkrete wahlversprechen wie wohin die
reise geht was ein mensch braucht oder
willkommenen thüringen viel weniger
inhalt geht gar nicht kurz im gespräch
waren auch frühstück ist die wichtigste
mahlzeit des tages und spargel wird
nicht trocken wenn sie ihn in ein
feuchtes tuch einschlagen was hören sie
mal ich könnte schwören de ist ein
linker achja gläubiger christ session
mit einer adligen verheiratet county
markus roth irrt in seiner ohne dieser
pseudo linke hat uns alle gelegt klar
anfang der neunziger dabei gewerkschafts
heilig und sah aus wie ein
serbokroatisch hütchenspieler aber heute
bruder und links im bundesrat hat er
sogar die blöde maut mit durchgewunken
als gegenleistung wird die zugstrecke
weimar gößnitz ausgebaut
der hat sich für eine handvoll schieden
schön auf den rücken gelegt wie so ein
kleines billiges bahncard flittchen also
man sagt er den ich ab und zu
linke sachen nein eben nicht das von
ground nur wähler
wenn überhaupt dann traut er sich setzen
wie und ehrlich gesagt ich finde es toll
dass es so was wie ein büro hundetag
gibt also ein tag an dem man sich
entscheidet sein haustier mit auf die
arbeit zu nehmen
klar der büro hundetag hat unser aller
leben verändert
dj bobo ist der lebende beweis du bist
als linker nur erfolgreich wenn keiner
merkt das tool links bist beim
kretschmann und den grünen genau
dasselbe nur in grün und ich arbeite
längst an einem neuen fall
nach meinen erkenntnissen ist dieser
mann gar nicht in der spd
[Musik]
das ist nun wirklich allgemeinwissen
dennis knossalla damen und herren guten
tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des heute
show youtube kanals begeistern schließt
gefälligst ein abo ab sofort